this is a production of Cornell
University
Thank You Ronnie
offering a very nice place for me to
study here okay uh hello everyone and
hello to the guys at Geneva okay I'm
very glad to be here to share with you
some interesting stories about Cornell's
Punk reading history based on my study
here I understand that my talk today is
very closely related to the previous one
of this series which was given by dr. Li
cast on last Tuesday
dr. Lee Kass talked about the whole
history more than 100 years history the
whole story of Cornell's plant breeding
while my talk today actually is about
some episodes in that history and some
aspects of some background stories
especially in terms of the international
involvement of Cornell's
from breeding talking about the
international involvement of done
breeding here I think most people will
think about a very well knowing project
conducted by Cornell University plump
reading Department and university of
Nanking China so that project has a very
very long official name here but from
here we can know who are the parties
working on that project and where the
where the founding come from but we can
easily remember this project as a very
short name the Cornell Nanking story and
most people also think that this story
is a beginning of Cornell's
international involvement in the field
of Agriculture especially to offer the
assistance to China's agriculture but to
my findings here I found the start point
should be much earlier when as early as
1897 in 1897 the first agriculturist
from Cornell going to China his name is
Gerald Riehl
he actually was boiling New York State
he had a family farm his family owned
the farm at that time he came to Cornell
to study agriculture in 1883 and after
five years he got his bachelor's degree
then he just went back to his family
farm - wrong that farm a few years later
he came back again for his graduate
study and also in the year of 1897 when
he came back in the same year he went to
China to help with the agricultural work
you may ask why why did he stop his
study and go to China because that was a
very early time it's really a kind of
matter of career courage a very
courageous trial to do that right so the
reason why he went here actually should
have started from this person this guy
is a very high-level or very influential
official in China at that time that was
in late Qing Dynasty that dynasty was
the last of feudalism dynasty in China's
history the late Qing Dynasty at that
time some of the officials or
intellectuals realized China needs some
reform especially in the fuse of
Agriculture so some of them especially
represented by this car decided to take
some reformed or take some trials to to
to do something on agricultural
improvements one of his trials is to try
to establish an agricultural school
although China has been leading in
agriculture for a very very long time
but that was a kind of traditional
cultural practice in terms of modern
agriculture he decided to have a school
to teach the Chinese people some more
than once some advanced agricultural
practice or technology oh I forgot to
talk about his name his name is Chun soo
don't he
Viceroy in province of central China
it's Hebei province of central China
where he decided to open us agriculture
school in modern sense he had to find
someone to work for him then he turned
to several foreigners who were in China
at that time for help to find a very
white person to do that job one of the
foreigners helped him his name is
Patrick he was a priest just working in
that province at that time he was a year
graduate but he didn't try to contact
his alma mater because he's thinking I
might be better in agriculture than
yield so he wrote a letter to Sherman
the third president of Cornell in
history and one more connection between
Sherman China is that after he left to
the presidency of Cornell here he was
appointed as the ambassador of the
United States to the Republican China
that's a later connection okay so
Patrick wrote this letter to Sherman and
Sherman give this letter to robbers
robbers was a Dean of College of
Agriculture Dan and he decided grill
might be the best candidate why because
the Viceroy requested that this
candidate should know well about modern
agriculture he should have a kind of
bility to teach agriculture as well as
to run a farm just like what I mentioned
Brill had the experience of running a
family farm and he learned agriculture
here so he might be the best candidate
to go to China
so finally real decided to take the job
then he went to China he went to try
just in the year of 1897 and after his
arrival in China he signs these
contracts with that Viceroy you can see
the contracts in english and chinese
languages and those contracts are still
kept in Canal archives very interesting
this M after one year I mean in the year
1898 Brill helped that Viceroy to
establish that I will culture school and
the school began to implore the first
group of civilian students in the year
of 1898 this is a notice or as for the
enrollment of that agricultural school
also kept in Canal archives and also in
that year I mean the first year of the
opening of that school real invited
another American people his cornelian
fellow Canadian named Gilmour to go to
China to work as his assistant so you
can see that from this picture there
were two American people with a group of
Chinese students but I should say
unfortunately they didn't I mean these
two guys didn't stay in China for a long
time because they cannot cause a lot of
difficulties for example one they too
would like to have a piece of field to
just build an experiment farm they had
to explain a lot to that Viceroy because
they will always ask how much money came
make from that farm because to Chinese
people's at that time to Chinese
people's concept of Agriculture they
just think oh the farm is just to make
money just to do agriculture production
just to get profit so they have to
explain a lot of times the experimental
farm is totally different from the
ordinary farm you cannot count on it to
make money you they are used for
experiment but they were not understood
well
that's one of the difficulties he came
across so just after three or four years
finally they to resign and come back to
America but one thing I would like to
mention in that reel has very good habit
he kept a very good collection of
different kinds of archives those
archives can to Cornell archives
I mean after his ass so you we can still
see a lot of pictures and newspapers
letters a lot of things different forms
in Cornell archives so those are very
valuable
I mean materials for people who are
interested in that part of the history
in Chinese agriculture you means you may
think hey this guy doesn't have anything
to do with camp reading because you're
talking about from reading in this
seminar right so the next thing I would
like to say is that his connection with
plant breeding is that before he went to
China he also visited that USDA and he
gotten kind of appointment he was
assigned as a special representative you
can see from this paper he was assigned
as a special representative of USDA to
China to do some investigation to do
some you know collection of the lung
resources in China so that means while
he was working for viceroy with that
agricultural school he also worked for
the usda to collect the plum resources
from the archives we know him from there
some some of the letters he wrote to the
usda we know that he once collected
quite a few different kinds of Klunk
resources and send them back the seeds
seedlings and those things were used a
later for trunk breeding experiment and
one more thing that Brio was connected
to plant breeding here is that after he
came back to america he actually had
been working on several farms as a
manager from the archives we know that
he kept very close and frequent
communication we start to love I think
you may know wo he walk he wants what
the head of the department of plant
breeding here from 1942 to 1949
and dr. love actually worked closely
with with Brio especially he talked love
did some research or experiment embryos
fun for for plant breeding or even for
extension work and dr. love by the way
he was also a very chief participant of
the Cornell Nanking story I I just
mentioned at the beginning before he
decided to go to China before he decided
to to have that project happen I mean
the Kony Onegin story happened he also
wrote the letters to brill to ask for
some suggestions or or some useful
information so there is another
connection between drill and Cornell's
plump reading but that's not mine and
that's not the main part of my story
today because those happened I mean Brio
went to China
that was in the Qing Dynasty not in the
Republic China the Qing Dynasty was
followed by the Republican China so what
I will focus on is a period of that
Republic China so within a period of
Republican China not only that was a
Viceroy I think more and more people
especially the officials and Inca
lectures they began to realize oh we
must do something on Chinese agriculture
it's there is a kind of urgent need to
improve on Chinese culture so that the
communication
in China and Western nations in terms of
agriculture developed very fast in that
period especially the sino us
communication in agriculture was the
fastest-growing one
I think this kind of communication took
place in two ways one if the Chinese
students came to studying in America
especially study agriculture here the
other way is that some if some American
agriculturists they won to China to
offer some help offer some instruction
beer all right we can just look at the
both of the ways the first way is the
Chinese people coming to America to
study agriculture I'm not trying to
glorify Cornell but I think talking
about sino-us communication in in
agriculture Cornell should be the one to
be named absent at first you can see
from the number from 1912 to 1927
altogether there are 170 students from
China they came to study in America for
agriculture among them 14 came to
Cornell that was the biggest queue
compared with a student to other
universities and in the following ten
years 190 students was sent by Chinese
government to study agriculture here and
one-third of them choose Cornell as
their University compared with the other
the students to other than University of
Michigan's Illinois's still the biggest
group so you can see Cornell isn't very
the first choice for the students to
study agriculture at that time and among
all the Chinese students come here this
guy should be named and I'm not sure
whether you know Chinese people all
American people know this guy very well
his name is who shoe doctor who she
actually graduated from Cornell and he
was considered as a key contributor to
China's language reform and liberalism
what's the connection between him and
agriculture actually this guy was
originally sent to Cornell to study I
will culture
but later he sought oh I'm not quite
interested in that I don't like that so
he changed his major to philosophy and
literature and he later worked as a
Minister of Education in Republic China
and one more thing interesting that is
that this guy also I he's a very
talented guy
he also took part in the English
speaking context of Cornell he beated
all the American students who speak
English as a native language and gods
our first Christ so yeah very
interesting but very talented people so
beside who she actually there are quite
a few very outstanding agriculturists in
the period of Republic in China actually
they graduated from Cornell then they
went back to serve their country alright
let's look at the other side the other
direction the American people
agriculturists going to China we should
name this one his name is Jung lossing
back he was a Canadian went to China in
1910s or something actually he was a
very person who established the first
Department of Agriculture economics in
China just the in the University of
Nanking and also he's a very person who
conducted the first investigation or
risk research on rural economy and farm
management in China so he was considered
actually a kind of father of the
discipline of agricultural economics in
China very influential still remembered
by people I mean doing agricultural
economics in China today but maybe also
to China to American people
most thing about him is that he got
married with her back this lady was a
daughter of a priest
in China then this lady actually was
born in China and grew up in China so
she spoke very good Chinese as well as
the English while after their marriage
she just went together with with dr.
buck to do those investigation in rural
areas and mainly just worked as a
translator or interpreter and later
probic wrote a novel named the good
earth based on his experience which is a
kind of a very vivid and good portrayal
of Chinese rural life in history and
because of that novel this lady was
awarded the Nobel Prize for Literature
in 1938 maybe he was saying hey you
should go to war to talk about to talk
about these guys because we are still
doing from breeding here I think so
the connection between this guy and from
breeding China is that the person
invited him to work in the university of
Nanking was Jung Henry Reisner that's
the main story I will talk about today I
will talk about this guy his life his
work his contributions in terms of plump
reading to Chinese to China's
agriculture before I talk about Reisner
I would like to have a few words on the
University of Nanking and the College of
their agriculture because at that time
he worked as a Dean of the College of Ag
agriculture in that University from here
we can see
the University of Nanking was funded
King was founded in 1918 eighty-eight
actually it was a private university
sponsored by American churches here and
it was proud to be the first educational
institution in China officially named as
University in English before that most
of the I mean institution were called
schools or something not the university
this was the first one to use university
as an English name and it was once in
once registered with the New York State
Education Department what does that mean
that means the students graduated from
that University they could come directly
to any University here in New York State
without taking any additional tests
their academic achievement will be
approved and accepted here in the
College of Agriculture in that
university was one of the strongest
college it was considered as it was
actually the first Institute in China to
offer four-year bachelor's degree in
education in field of agriculture so
that it was considered I mean that
establishment of that college was
considered as a beginning of China's
modern higher education in agriculture
their meaningful step and that college
later involved into the current Nanjing
agriculture university that's a
university I'm now working with so
that's why I'm here I'm quite
interesting in this part of the story
okay so
I think one of the reason why the
College of Agriculture is very strong is
that it once got involved in the Cornell
Nanking project on the ranking story
project stop requested alright okay uh
yeah that's the reason why the college
was very strong just because of that
project those faculty will get we're
trained by the American experts and the
research research ability what improved
a lot of result achieved from that
project okay then I would just go on to
talk about the ricer under the guy
wisely you can see from here if you are
interesting in that story I would
recommend you to have a look up this
book it can be downloaded from online
now you can see from here actually this
book was co-authored by two persons
Reisner and talked to Liz I think yeah
this is a Chinese version we just
translated and published it in China I
got involved in translation so yeah I
like this story those are the two
authors
I think compared with dr. love Reisner
also did very great job in that history
in that project but he was not
remembered as much as dr. love so that's
why I would like to give you more
stories and things about Weisner today
and first we should know how significant
this person is from the canal Alumni
news from a new story it was once said
to be perhaps the foremost Graduate
performing outstanding service to
agriculture by canal in China and here
is a buyer sketch of this person
although actually he did mostly he did a
lot of running mission work religious
service in other developing nations but
he also did a lot of agricultural work
so I still think that he is an
agriculturist he was born in Virginia
and grew up in Pennsylvania he went to
ear college in 1907 and after four years
he got a bachelor's degree in arts just
remember he got a degree in arts not in
agriculture and later just because of
his contribution to agriculture mission
work I'm not sure whether you're
familiar with agriculture mission work
actually in the history some American
churches they wish to combine the
mission work and agricultural services
together so that the churches can
participate more in those rural areas
services and to increase their influence
in those developing nations so actually
he devoted most of his life to the
agricultural mission work then he was
awarded the honorary degree of Master of
Arts in 1950 by his eminent modern year
university okay the year College
actually was the undergraduate college
of university in history and yeah
died in New York State he mostly yeah I
did most of the I were commissioned work
after he came back he came back from
China in 1931 after he came back he
basically worked with this organization
and he also in 1950s he once worked as
the observer for various church agencies
with FAO and also he was a member of the
Advisory Committee of the technical
cooperation administration that's the
that was also called the point full
program in history recommended by by
President Truman in American history
just mainly focusing on having some
cooperation technical cooperation with
other developing nations all right so
that's why he was also related to
President Truman's point full program
you may still have this question
he was year graduate a Bachelor of ours
how did he turn to do agriculture plumb
reading how was he connected with palm
reading so actually the story started
from this movement the student volunteer
movement of foreign missions because he
graduate in it from ill in 1911 that was
just the peak time of the student
volunteer movement of foreign missions
thousands of college student graduated
from university then they went to other
nations to do some religious service
full of passion and Reisner was one of
them and
from the oral history and also I tried I
tried to contact the descendants of half
of riser and his granddaughter
offered me some very valuable
information and documents from those
part of the image from those materials I
got to know that after he graduated from
yield
he was firstly offered a job to teach
biology in University of Nanking because
that university was sponsored by
American churches so he was actually a
mathematics major in Neil
and he thought maybe I cannot teach
biology very well at that time he got to
know that the College of Agriculture
will be established in the university of
Nanking he thought hey and more
interested in teaching agriculture
because I was this an agriculture while
I was a young because he helped him you
know to do some farm work while he was
young but he still didn't think that he
has got enough preparation to teach
agriculture to China then he just came
to Cornell in 1912 to attend some summer
school courses that experience really
opened the eyes of reissner's to the
modern agriculture and advanced
agriculture then he decided to go on he
came back in 1913 to register for his
master degree and under yeah his major
was farm crops and his minor was just
plunk reading under the professor
Gilbert he was also member of the plum
breeding departments synapses Club dr.
Leale talked about this club last week
it's a club for the plum breeding
faculty and students to meet regularly
to have dinners to have social lives to
even have seminars all right so from
this picture we can see this young
gentleman was wiser and his professor
Gilbert was sitting at the front row
yeah actually just in one year he
finished all the required courses for
his master degree not
he finished his courses in 1914
but he didn't have enough time to finish
his thesis then he had to go he had to
go to to leave for China actually he
finished the his thesis in China why he
was looking in University of Nanking his
thesis is about the wit history the the
wheat planting history in New York State
and also he got his master degree in the
year of 1915 while he was in Nanjing
yeah Nanjing is that the current name
the city used to be called Nanking but
now he's called Nanjing okay so yeah
before he went to China he got to know a
girl named Bertha bets that girl was a
auto student in a major of home
economics in the same College and before
he went to China he decided to take her
together was with him to go to China
then the NGO agreed they just went
together okay yeah while they were in
China mostly most of the time from I
mean upon his arrival in two years
Reisner was was working on the faculty
at the University of Nanking in the
College of Agriculture and for the rest
more than 10 years he worked as a Dean
or coding because for political reasons
sometimes they have to you know carry
out a system of the coding with the
Chinese people working as another coding
so that they were not you know rejected
by Chinese people just too for some
period of time in history so he worked
as adding or coding for more than 15
years yeah something about his
mrs. rice also did something while he
was in Nanjing
he developed a cookbook the purpose of
the dispo cookbook is to teach those non
Chinese people who were living at China
to use some foodstuff grown locally to
cook some dishes and that book was
actually published in also in English
and Chinese also you can get a copy from
Cornell archives okay if you wanna have
a look on this book alright let's go
back to Riesling story
a chi reissner's oral history and to the
literature I found actually why Scott
was the second person in China who had a
master's degree in either in either
agriculture or in forestry the first guy
was a Chinese person he graduated from
Michigan State University and majoring
in forestry then he went back earlier
then Reister but in the university of
Nanking he was a first person on the
faculty with any training in agriculture
considering the University of Nanking
was very leading in agriculture at that
time in China so we can see that
reissner's work might be very pioneering
of or running in China especially to
China's agriculture and competing okay
so rice the record almost anything that
when did in China at that time was a
first very meaningful insignificant and
wise that failed that his most notable
achievement that he made in China was
definitely in crop breeding and
improvements so to my understanding or
my story we'll talk about his work in
China just by two parts one part of his
contribution is that he Institute
instituting the Cornell Nanking story
that we just mentioned a later I will
give you more background information on
this story the other part of his
achievements is that he did some
personal trial on Plum breeding
experiment and also God's success in
that period very meaningful thing very
early just upon his arrival in 1914 he
just started to to do something on
prompt reading
he might be the first person to plot to
treat you have brought the modern
technology of plant breeding to China
and to use that okay those are something
from his oral history actually from here
we know that he did run breeding mainly
on two crops one is on wheat and the
other one is on corn or maize all right
so he said he developed the first pure
string of wheat from a single plant and
had a very good yield and that variety
was used as a Czech variety for a period
of time and for the corn he also
developed a Chinese yellow corn from
selections and that corn also was proved
to be very successful in some parts of
China let's look at the wheat first the
wheat actually to Chinese literature
that weed was named as a number 26
developed by Reissner and here is a
table from a report of Meijer my
instructor Myers was also one of the
participants in Canal Nanking story
he worked in China for set a for a
period of time before he left he just
submitted a report on his work in China
in that report we can see this table you
can see that here the standard variety
is number six number six he used as of
standard variety and it had it has got a
better yield than those average farm
varieties in in terms of the corn the
corn that he developed was named as a
Nanking yellow keep him at this corn by
year to row method
that was a actually this method was
already commonly used in American
experiment stations but the first time
to be used in China and it was proved to
be very very successful especially in
the area of Yangtze River so from those
successful experience Reisner has got
more confidence in doing plant breeding
in China
he said increased agricultural
production China will come most easily
and quickly through increasing yield by
scientific ground selection ok those are
the those are some of his personal
trials in from breeding and the second
part of his contribution is about the
colony linking story I would like to
give you some background stories about
this one so actually the canal linking
story started because a theorist family
in the White River that's central China
by River in 1920 the in President Wilson
set up a committee by responding to to
responded to that famine serious serious
famine by setting up a committee to
raise a big sum of money to do the
family relief work but later that relief
work ended sooner or earlier than
expected the committee found out you
still have a very big sum of money not
used how could they use this money in a
very wise way very wide way or very
effective way then Reisner just at that
time got to the news god got to know the
news and he submitted a proposal to that
committee saying that this money could
be used in a long run fanning prevention
instead of a short-run famine relief
work especially that could be used in
agriculture then that proposal was
approved the college of agriculture got
seven hundred fifty thousand dollars
that's really a very big sum of money
then that's why the Cornell Nanking
story happened
but the next for next step for Reisner
to do is to design a concrete scheme or
design what really he needs to do with
that money
then he designed a very comprehensive
project especially in the field of [ __ ]
reading because we mentioned he has got
a lot of confidence in from reading then
he choose from reading as a main work of
the design project he then in 1924 he
wrote to dr. love at from reading here
to discuss on the possibility to invite
some American experts to come to China
to work and cooperate on from reading so
in brief that project finally involved
three experts from Konya plunk reading
they just went to China in turn each one
being there for for one year but each
one of them just went to China twice
each time one year there they did a lot
of things in China they taught lessons
they taught you know gave lectures they
instructed the experiment they helped
with the extension work they did a lot
of things you can see that you know
actually it's a kind of transferring off
the land ground mode land-grant college
mode from Cornell to to University of
Nanking especially the College of
Agriculture there so just because it's a
very comprehensive project the result
achieved from the project is also very
comprehensive the less people were
trained the high yield crops were
achieved and the method was standardized
a lot of achievements what were got from
that very successful Cornell Nanking
story projects and one more thing about
this project I mean the long lasting
effect of that project is that it was
commonly considered as a first notable
example of international technical
cooperation in agriculture so that's why
it's also related to the recommendation
for President Truman for US government's
Honfleur program that's a technical
cooperation program
and also with this with the success of
the Cornell Nanking story there is a
following success of the Cornell Law
Spanier story all right some comment
from you know the other people on
reissner's work and contributing China
this guy
this person is dr. Zhang Zhang Han he is
a very outstanding plant breeder in
China's agricultural history especially
in the period of the Republic in China
but he went to Taiwan you know during
the time of committing communist China
he did a lot of contribution not only to
China's agriculture but also to
agriculture of Southeast Asia he was a
student of dr. earth he was also
Canadian graduate he was in the year of
1935 he once made a speech talking about
the development of China's plum greeting
creole he made a reflection that China's
plant breeding started from 1915 the
first 10 years was just like so a
person's childhood and in the year of
1925 it was transferred or transited to
a kind of person's childhood I'm sorry a
teenager teenager years ok the first 10
years and second 10 years different
period and you can see from the timing
the starting the ORAC the origin of
China's plunk reading actually it's
about a time while Weiser just arrived
in China and started his trial in plum
breeding and your transition year is
also the time Weisner started and
instituted that well knowing Cornell
Nanking story project
so both stages are very closely related
to this guy and the doctor should also
named several representative persons for
the two stages of Chinese you know
starting years of plum reading and
Reisner was named respectively for the
two stages okay
finally some epilogue for my talk today
I although I focus on Reisman's
contribution to Chinese agriculture to
Chinese plum breeding but we should
always remember that it's never a
one-way traffic it's always a wing wing
project only in this way can such kind
of cooperation be very successful and
sustainable for example canal staff and
students may get a very global vision
from such kind of experience they may
yeah they may have more knowledge of the
situation different areas of on the word
and besides that they also can have some
valuable plant resources and in history
from such kind of cooperation one very
good example is about dr. love and he's
one party story which was also told in
doctor loves book the corny on Nanking
story okay in brief the one party is a
party variety brought by talk to love
from China to to America he used that in
plant breeding experiment and later that
that variety was used for extension and
got a very big profit for New York wheat
industry and the variety was named as
war marriages because a Chinese
assistant working with Whistler while he
was in China
oh the person who firstly saw that
variety his name his last name was one
so that was why it was named as one
party all right since you know it's
always the kind of mutually beneficial
project so
even nowadays I still think they were
much it's much easier or there are more
opportunities than before to make such
kind of wing wing project happen in
current time or in the future maybe even
not only maybe not only just beneficial
to the two parties of the cooperation
but even beneficial to the global
agriculture so if you have not visited
China if you have not worked with
Nanjing Agricultural University come on
now it's a chance so I think a new Canal
Nanking story is just waiting for you to
Institute and participate I'm very glad
to be the liaison person or to offer
some information that you're interested
okay that's all for my talk thank you
very much I would like to thank this
persons and some of the institutions who
just helped me with my study one year
study here and if you have any questions
just unvaried glad to to answer that I
think language Berry is always a problem
but that's not the biggest problem
those those American people they want to
China they I I don't I don't think they
learn much Chinese but Chinese people
maybe they mostly the Chinese people
just help to translate or they speak
they spoke China English very well so
that we can just work together with with
those American people there nowadays I
think things are much better now Chinese
people may be speak I think that if more
and more Chinese people speak better
English so if you want to go there don't
worry about language
[Music]
yes yes that's actually from those early
archives of those Chinese students
coming here especially I just mentioned
dr. fouch actually there also is there's
also kind of huge box of papers about
him not not a who shoot those papers not
kept by Russia but kept a lady who was
American people she hosted Russia in her
family he kept a very good collection of
different kind of a pers about this
person and from those papers we can find
very interesting stories while those
student just came in and how they
settled down how they got used to the
culture here and a very interesting
things that also who she's mother there
also intellectual China she wrote a
letter to the American lady to show her
appreciation of course in Chinese and
who should translate it that being very
very good English
I really admire his English actually
just like the English people wrote wrote
that letter I think after a few years
here who sure just got used to I mean
the culture and yes that's good question
during that period most of the college
students were moved they have to move to
the southwest of China so actually
during I mean within the history of our
university there was one part that the
university was based in another province
in china but there was still some
foreigners they stayed in there because
a sitting Nanjing because you know they
are American people they're foreigners
they were a little bit different from
the Chinese people the Japanese invaders
they
they maybe they are not you know to
anything easily on them so they were I
remember there was one American people
his name's riggers and he actually is
the England field of agricultural
engineering he also got some was
founding a sponsor from Cornell in China
club because at that time there was a
kind organization named Cornell in China
Club the club is just to promote a
communication between Korea and China
the club just offered some funding to to
that American people to do some teaching
and research in China he was a very
important important person to work in a
kind of safe zone to protect a lot of
Chinese people who left and didn't
leaving but it we didn't run away in
Nanjing at that time that's very
interesting
touching story thank you for question
[Music]
yes you might be interesting that okay
that's very interesting story during the
Cultural Revolution
you know the Chairman Mao at that time
he thought that the Agricultural
University they should go to the rural
area so that they can be very close to
agriculture then those agricultural
universities all of them just moved to
very rather remote or rural area there
is small country or something like that
I should say the research the teaching
were actually interrupted because of you
know you know that at that time most of
the you know there was always a kind of
chaos in the society so the student
teachers they cannot you know have a
very good environment to study and do
research so yeah they were moved out of
the city but after the Revolution a
cultural evolution most of them all of
them just came back yeah
Oh in my university was also moved to a
very small city not far from the Nanjing
but in 1981 it was moved back to the
city of Nanjing
any questions
so start eerie oscillating how many
people in this world yes
oh that's great yes much more than my
expectation okay so what about the rest
wants would you like to go there if yes
okay so that's my purpose I'm giving a
talk today this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at cornell
edu